So as bones grow, the cells that are
growing inside the bone are FGFR3-positive cells. What this
means? If we zoomed in really close is that
the cells in red, if we look very close
up, here is the cell membrane. This red protein
here is the FGFR3 protein. We have two proteins
right here, and they're embedded in the membrane. As
you can imagine, proteins in the membrane are important,
because they're what communicate from the outside
world to the inside world. Now if there
are actually two FGFR3 proteins like this, they're
considered inactive. Nothing is happening Because the only
way the FGFR3 protein can do anything is if it's bound to it's favorite
partner protein FGF3. The R in FGFR3
stands for Receptor, because it receives the signal from FGF3. It's
like it's serving as a docking platform. So
these two FGFR3 proteins can get close together. And
once they're close together, then there's a signal that's
sent to slow down bone growth. So normally these
cells in red, that are FGRF3 positive are growing
and dividing and contributing to the cells in the
long bone, helping it to grow longer. But there
is a signal that comes from the environment that
is transmitted through the FGRF3 protein. So
that whenever the FGF3 protein is around, it's
a signal that says, whoa, slow down, guys.
Slow down your bone growth. Now, what happens
in the case of the G1138A mutation? The misense mutation is that right here in
this region with printing spans across the cell
membrane that's where the amino acid changes happen.
And now this FGFR3 protein doesn't have to wait for FGF3. It can form this pair
what we call a dimerization. Dimer di meaning two here. Even when there's no
protein partner to facilitate the interaction. Right?
We don't see that yellow protein here connecting
the two FGFR3s. So this means we're going
to slow down bone growth like we normally
would, but now its going to happen even when the FGF3 isn't around. So the net
effect are bones that grow shorter than they
normally would. Because the FGF3 protein is going to be
slowing bone growth down, even when the FGF3
isn't around. It means that this protein is
sort of always on now. Overall, this results
in a form of short limb dwarfism called achondroplasia.
If you want to know where the name comes
from, a chondrocyte is what we call a bone cell
a chondrocyte. So the chondro part is what we're
referring to a bone here. Plasia means growth, so chondroplasia
means bone growth and achondroplasia means the absence or
the loss of so The loss of bone growth. And
that's what dwarfism is, in this sense. A person with
achondroplasia will have shorter limbs. And overall, be a shorter
person with a distinctive facial structure also due to
altered bone development of the skull. So would you
categorize this allele here, the G1138A allele. As a
loss-of-function, a gain-of-function, or no change in function allele.